buenas noches nuevo avance informativa
en france 24 en español las fuerzas
militares de eeuu llevaron a cabo en las
últimas horas lo que calificaron como
ataques aéreos de precisión defensivos
esto en la región fronteriza entre irak
y siria según el comunicado del
pentágono los ataques tuvieron como
objetivo instalaciones operativas y de
almacenamiento de armas en dos lugares
en siria y uno en irak que eran
utilizados por milicias respaldadas por
iran comprometidas en ataques aéreos
contra personal e instalaciones
estadounidenses en irak los ataques
sobre los cuales el pentágono no
especificó si dejaron muertos o heridos
se llevaron a cabo por orden del
presidente joe biden quien evitó
pronunciarse sobre el tema en su regreso
a la casa blanca
y francia vivió hoy la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones regionales y tanto la
ultraderecha como el oficialismo
volvieron a sufrir reveses al igual que
en la primera vuelta del pasado 20 de
junio la jornada estuvo marcada por el
abstencionismo que volvió a situarse
alrededor del 66% el partido del
presidente de manuel macro no obtuvo la
victoria en ninguna de las 13 regiones
metropolitanas mientras que la derecha
de los republicanos y sus aliados fueron
los grandes vencedores y se impusieron
ante el partido ultraderechista
agrupación nacional de marine lepén que
tenía puesto los ojos en la región
provenza-alpes-costa azul y fracasó en
su intento por lograr por primera vez
dirigir un gobierno regional de esta
manera se manifestaba la líder
ultraconservadora escuchemos sus ojos
esta noche no vamos a tomar ninguna
región porque los dirigentes de turno
ayudados por alianzas contra las leyes
de la naturaleza han hecho todo lo
posible para impedirnos mostrar a los
franceses nuestra capacidad para dirigir
una administración regional la
importante progresión entre las dos
rondas de votación es la región para acá
sigue siendo insuficiente para que
tengamos una victoria demuestra que la
movilización es la clave para las
victorias
y continuamos con noticias que llegan
desde eeuu y es que aumentó a 9 el
número de personas fallecidas tras el
colapso parcial del edificio de 12 pisos
ocurrido durante la madrugada del jueves
pasado en search side cerca de miami
cuatro de los fallecidos ya fueron
identificados y la policía local dio a
conocer sus nombres mientras alrededor
de 150 personas permanecen desaparecidas
y los equipos continúan con las labores
de búsqueda a los rescatistas
estadounidenses se sumaron equipos de
méxico y de israel como refuerzo por su
parte la vicegobernadora de florida
aseguró que van a continuar con las
labores
de momento 9
el gobernador asado
asegurando a todo
todos los recursos
con
y finalizamos con deportes noticias del
tour de francia el neerlandés +
vanderpool logró una impresionante
victoria en lo que fue la segunda etapa
de la competencia en el muro de bretaña
el ciclista que debuta en esta edición
del tour se vistió con el maillot
amarillo tras ganar las dos
bonificaciones de la etapa y superar en
la meta a los eslovenos atrás de época
char actual campeón de la vuelta gala y
primos rowling el francés julian a la
philippe que venció durante la primera
etapa este sábado hoy quedó en quinto
lugar
llegamos hasta aquí con este avance
informativo pero sigan con nosotros
porque hay muchísimo más en france 24 y
en france 24 punto con gracias por
acompañarnos